Blut vitamin b12 von chlorophyll das alles sind moleküle aus der natur mit wirklich wichtigen funktionen
aber sie können noch viel mehr und zwar
im bereich technik sie alle bauen auf einem bestimmten organischen molekül auf und genau dieses sorgt für
Sensationelle erfolge wenn man es in elektroden von batterien eingebaut denn dieses molekül
steigert die
ladegeschwindigkeit
von batterien erlauben ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts wie genau verkürzen diese moleküle die ladezeit der akkus so kurz und kann dadurch die bislang so
umweltschädliche batterieherstellung nachhaltiger werden das alles und viel mehr jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Das ist wirklich ein dauerthema denn das nervt wirklich alle smartphone besitzer und besitzerinnen
täglich immer wenn gerade ein wichtiger anruf reinkommt oder man eine nachricht versenden will
Macht das akku schlapp dazu kommt die gefühlt
so unfassbar lange und lässt siege ladezeit der akkus deswegen
berichten wir immer wieder mal von forschungsteams weltweit die mit innovativen ideen dieses
akku problem endlich lösen wollen die weltweit verbreitetste batterie technologie basiert auf
lithium ionen batterien eingesetzt in laptops kameras handys und fast allen anderen
technischen geräten denn bislang gibt es einfach keinen anderen elektrischen energiespeicher der
wiederaufladbar ist und vergleichbar gute eigenschaften in der anwendung hat aber fest steht auch für die gewinnung und
Bereitstellung der benötigten rohstoffe wie lithium selbst nickel mangan und kobalt
als elektrodenmaterial gehen große
umweltrisiken aus genau deswegen suchen forschungsteams weltweit nach möglichkeiten um
hochleistungsfähige
speichermaterialien zu entwickeln die auf nachwachsenden rohstoffen basieren diesen plan sind jetzt wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
des karlsruher instituts für technologie kit näher gekommen denn sie haben entdeckt dass das molekül für
Ihn die ladegeschwindigkeit von batterien deutlich in die höhe treibt im labor wurden
speicherkapazitäten von 130 bis
170 milliarden stunden programm gemessen bei einer mittleren spannung von 3 volt die be- und entladung dauer lag dabei bei nur einer minute
Wow das forschungsteam ist optimistisch die
speicherkapazität um weitere 100 milliarden stunden programm
Zu steigern zudem ist der plan den speicher neben lithium auch mit natrium zu betreiben dies würde die
batterieherstellung sehr viel nachhaltiger machen den atrium ist als rohstoff deutlich häufiger verfügbar
Das organische molekül namens purr für ihn ist im übrigen keineswegs unbekannt
Im gegenteil ist es in der natur sehr verbreitet dieses molekül bildet das grundgerüst von
Chlorophyll also dem blattgrün zudem ist es auch das gerüst des blutfarbstoffs von mensch und tier auch
hämoglobin genannt und zudem bildet es auch die basis von vitamin b12 und
Die leistungssteigerung in den laborexperimenten kann sich wirklich sehen lassen dazu maximilian fichtner einer der beteiligten forscher
Die speicher eigenschaften sind außergewöhnlich war das material eine speicherkapazität
Wie eine batterie material besitzt aber so schnell arbeitet wie ein super kondensator
letzterer weisen zwar nur etwa zehn prozent der energiedichte von konventionellen akkus auf dabei ist ihre
leistungsdichte bis zu hundertfach größer so dass sie sehr viel schneller
Und entladen werden können um diese eigenschaft
zu erreichen versetzte das forschungsteam
aus karlsruhe das organische molekül kupfer porphyry mit organischen gruppen diese führten dazu dass sich das material in der
batteriezelle
strukturell und elektrisch vernetzt die struktur der elektroden wurde so extrem stabilisiert mehrere tausend lade und entladezyklen
Wurden wie möglich gemacht wenn er immer als erstes neues zum thema batterietechnologie und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
endet meine nummer hier von whatsapp hier der link
Bei, euch dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen von mir vom neuesten video direkt wenn es hochgeladen wurde garantiert
er könnten direkt in der redaktion von blick so mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder
über abstimmungen mitbestimmen was hierbei clixoom läuft einfach da drauf kriegen natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter auch dafür. Draufklicken elektroautos revolutionäres neues batterie konzept ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran